welcome everyone
thank you all for being here
my name is Landon Starbuck and I'm the
founder of an organization combating
child exploitation and trafficking in
America
we're here today to protect children
from Child mutilation
I am honored to join forces today with a
daily wire Matt Walsh and we are so
grateful to the survivors of the
horrific child mutilation taking place
in our state to the survivors of radical
gender ideology that devastates families
that decimates children's bodies and
does not protect them or give them the
health care they need and deserve that
is why we're here today and there is
nothing that is going to stop us from
delivering that important message
I'd like to take a moment to say that we
are a peaceful loving movement
advocating for the safety of children
and we will not be drowned out by
hateful bigoted people who care nothing
about what's right
we ask you to open your hearts right now
and recognize that we live in a greatest
country in the world where we still have
the freedom of speech and with that said
I'd like to Lead You In saying our
Pledge of Allegiance
I'm gonna fickle [ __ ] out there
I pledge allegiance to the flag of the
United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for all
it's my honor to introduce our first
Speaker here
the organizer of today's rally he was
one of the very first to publicly
question and call out gender ideology
when others remain silent he brought to
light how pediatric hospitals around the
country including Vanderbilt University
Medical Center here in Nashville
Vanderbilt they're profiting off of
so-called gender affirming care
he revealed that one Vanderbilt Doctor
Who boasted about how the surgeries and
drugs that they administer on children
are quote a huge money maker
[Applause]
but our first speaker is not just
exposing the lies and harm befalling our
children he's taking real action to stop
it he is a best-selling author creator
of the groundbreaking documentary what
is a woman
and the host of the Matt wall show on
The Daily wire
tennesseans please join me in welcoming
the Matt Walsh
hello
thank you
thank you everyone
I want to thank all of our speakers for
being a part of this event
we're going to hear from a wide range of
voices today
so activists academics politicians
D transitioners and I'm very grateful
for all of them
I want to thank especially
all of you for coming out here today
to show your support for this cause
now these people here they don't want
you to hear what we have to say because
they're cowards they can't engage in the
argument
all they could try to do is shut us down
and silence us but it's not going to
work we're still here
we're not going anywhere
we're still here
so what is the cause that we are here
for it's very simple we are here to
fulfill one of our most fundamental
obligations As Americans as adults as
human beings
and that is to protect our children
that is why we're here
if we if we will not stand up for them
then who will if it's not us then who
stands for them the people out there
shouting they're not going to stand for
the kids
they stand for victimizing and Prey Upon
kids so it falls to us
now here's the fact of the matter there
is in this state and all across the
country a conspiracy to Target and
indoctrinate our children into the Cults
of gender ideology
a cult which Fosters delusion
intentionally creates an identity crisis
and young impressionable kids
it's a cult which convinces them that
gender doesn't exist that they have no
identity it's a path to confusion and
despair
now for years this has been happening
right here in the state of Tennessee not
far from where we currently stand
as my team and I uncovered Vanderbilt
Hospital got into the gender transition
game because it's quote a big money
maker those are their own words
and soon they were drugging and
mutilating adults as well as children
now
let me ask you let me ask you guys this
as tennesseans
do we believe in castrating children do
we believe in that
no
do we believe in drugging and mutilating
kids
they believe in it we don't
are we going to allow this in our state
[Applause]
are we going to do what they want us to
do which is sit back in silence and
allow our kids to be victimized are we
now I have four kids and I have two more
on the way and like so many of you I
live every day constantly aware of the
world that's out there of these people
who want to Prey Upon my kids
my kids have no idea you know what these
people will try to do to them it's not
fair it's not it's not right that our
kids live in a culture in a country like
that
but here's the thing I'm not going to
leave it
to my kids to fight this fight we don't
leave it to our kids we stand up and we
fight
okay it isn't
it isn't our kids battle it's ours
and we're not just fighting to protect
our kids from mutilation
in the name of gender transition we're
fighting that but an even deeper level
we are fighting for truth
that's what we stand for we stand for
absolute truth
that's what we stand for right there
and that brings me
to one final point that I need to make
the other side the side that supports
mutilating and drugging kids
they know they have no argument
they have nothing they can say so they
lie and one of the most ridiculous lies
that they tell
is that they want to affirm kids
they're not affirming the child they're
affirming confusion they're affirming
despair
that's what they're affirming
[Applause]
[Music]
now we do not affirm confusion we affirm
the child
when a child is confused we affirm him
we give him the sort of affirmation that
he desperately Longs for and needs and
deserves
that's what we do
now
that's our message
and it's a message that we hope
resonates not just across the city or
this state but all across the country
because we're building a movement and
we're not going anywhere
we're not going to rest
we're not going to rest
until every child is protected from this
madness
so the other side they can shout and
they can scream and they could call us
whatever names they want none of that
will dissuade us because this is a
battle of good versus evil
and we are fighting for good
we're fighting for what is true
we're fighting for people who cannot
fight for themselves and shouldn't have
to that's what we're fighting for
we're in this for the Long Haul for as
long as it takes right this is only the
beginning I promise you that
thank you all God bless thank you
foreign
[Applause]
I want to thank you all for being here
because without you being here nothing
gets done change doesn't happen in
Washington it doesn't even happen across
the street it happens right here with We
the People
and we have been on the side of being
civil and kind
we have not screamed as other people
have screamed at us what we're trying to
be heard we are the ones being censored
on social media this is a last standing
Public Square in America where we can
free speak freely and we will not be
silenced by people with fascist mindsets
who want to quiet us
[Applause]
foreign
like I said my name is Landon Starbuck
and I run a non-profit here in Tennessee
combating child exploitation every
single day we deal with survivors of the
same thing that you're advocating for
right here
survivors of the most horrific realities
we deal with families right now with
children over at the gender clinic and
they're on the end of the most horrific
procedures that they regret and they
fear speaking out because of hateful
Behavior like this that's why it is so
important that we become that voice and
we get louder and we become Fearless
the days of an apathetic attitude
towards standing up for what is Right
are over
we're standing in this great state of
Tennessee for what we believe is right
and I want to let you know of what's to
come if we don't continue standing up if
we don't find our brothers and sisters
and help them join this movement they
want to take the children away from
parents who refuse gender affirmative
care who refuse to cut off the healthy
breasts of their children
just a few weeks ago my organization
went after a doctor here in Nashville
Tennessee with a photo of the naked
breasts of a 15 year old girl on his
website for profit that is not okay
and that is legal in this state and in
America
because it's not being used for sexual
purposes but let me tell you something I
fight sexual exploitation every day and
gender ideology and radical sexual
ideology are deeply intertwined you
cannot separate them they come together
they're here to sexualize our children
they will not stop until we stop them
so I ask you to join me and stand Fierce
and strong in the next phase of this
child rights agenda because if they
believe that children can consent to
dangerous life-changing medical
procedures what else do they think
children can consent to
[Applause]
we will never allow the United States to
be taken down by this fascist extremist
sexualization of children movement
children are not sexual keep your hands
off our children
with that said I'd like to welcome our
next guest please welcome the president
of the convention of states and one of
the nation's most effective Grassroots
activists and lawyers mark meckler
[Applause]
[Music]
it is great to be in Tennessee is it not
and I gotta say of all the people I
follow in the media the guy that's out
there putting it on the line making the
difference actually doing the stuff
let's hear it from Matt Walsh
[Applause]
[Music]
look this is really important because
Matt's actually willing to do what it
takes to make a difference a lot of
people in the media are out there and
they're talking and we've been hearing a
lot of talking for a lot of years how
many people think that the time for talk
is over
this is the time for action and there is
nothing more important than we can do
than take care of our kids and there is
nothing worse that we could do for our
kids than to butcher kids who are just
teenagers who have no idea what's going
on am I right
now I understand in the American Body
politic we can have differences and we
do have differences and I was out there
walking through the crowd earlier and
what I saw is the folks that are out
there that want to protect our kids are
willing to have dialogue and those that
want to mutilate our kids want to shut
you down are you going to let them shut
you down
I would say hell no we're tired of being
shut down
this is about human rights and we need
to protect our kids and if we're not
willing to stand up and protect our kids
then we're not for human rights how many
of you are going to stand up from now on
and protect the kids
[Applause]
the guy got to say there's a lot of
people in the media that I respect a lot
of people out there willing to take a
stand a lot of people willing to engage
in fights but the guy that's at the
point of the spear the god that's
willing to actually do something is Matt
Walsh and I say God bless Matt Walsh
look I love seeing brave people in the
fight and one of my favorite people out
there in the fight now is somebody that
had the opportunity to meet recently she
is a brave Warrior for what's right
she's willing to stand up and tell the
truth no matter the cost please welcome
former congresswoman 2020 presidential
candidate veteran and host of the new
podcast the Tulsi gabbard show Tulsi
gabbard
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you aloha
thanks to all of you who have gathered
here today on such an important issue as
We Gather here this year we're
celebrating the 50th anniversary of the
enactment of Title IX
Title IX was created as of out of a
recognition of the biological difference
between men and women and we as women
have had great opportunity and
advancement because of it
where we are now today though is those
in power denying the existence of women
they are seeking to erase us as an
entire category of people
and even more dangerously they are
denying the existence of objective truth
without recognition that there is such a
thing as truth
There Are No Boundaries in our society
which is why we are where we are today
who is suffering as a consequence of
these actions it is the most vulnerable
among us our children that is why we are
gathered here today to stand up for our
kids
to be their voice
because our kids are having their
childhood stolen from them
I think there are a lot of you who are
here who may be able to relate women
here I grew up a tomboy I thought the
boys were having all the fun I cut my
hair short I wanted nothing more than to
be a boy because it was cool and it was
fun
but guess what life moved on I moved on
and I grew up
I cannot imagine the kinds of pressures
that are happening with our kids today
with our young girls who are tomboys
this is what's at stake here we have
people who are undermining our parents
using the threat of the rule of law to
take away their right and responsibility
to raise our kids
forcing compliance and trying to silence
those of us who are here to speak up and
fight for our kids
our kids need us now
they need to hear our voices speaking up
for them
they need to hear your voices of Courage
Your Voice of Truth
exercise your right to free speech
exercise your voice and cast your vote
because who in power matters
there is so much at stake here in this
next election it is nothing short than
our freedom
the Safety and Security of our kids and
our families
and our future
so don't let anyone silence your voice
don't let anyone push you to the
sideline
stand up and speak out because our kids
their well-being and their lives are
what's at stake
thank you so much everybody
stand strong keep fighting aloha
[Applause]
all right please welcome our next guest
senior council at Alliance defending
freedom and an outspoken advocate for
women's rights especially in sports
please welcome Christiana Kiefer
[Music]
good afternoon
over the past several years we've
watched with increasing alarm as
vulnerable children have become the
objects of a political experiment
vulnerable distressed confused children
and Adolescence instead of being given
the psychiatric help that they need are
told they were born in the wrong body
and are put on a conveyor belt of
off-label puberty blockers synthetic
hormones and even life-altering
surgeries
but instead of caring for the child's
underlying distress the science shows
this conveyor belt leads to more pain
the full risks are not yet known but
what we do know is enough to pull the
plug on this entire political experiment
off labor off label puberty blockers and
cross-sex hormones result in decreased
bone density increased cardiovascular
and cancer risk impaired brain function
liver dysfunction and permanent
sterility
teen girls who had their healthy breasts
removed are never able to nurse children
boys who permanently block puberty never
reach sexual maturity and can't father
children and that's in addition to the
risks and complications associated with
these irreversible surgeries this is not
Health Care these are dangerous
unscientific and unregulated experiments
with permanent effects and they're being
perpetrated by ideologues and activists
on our children children are not
political experiments
foreign
if kids lack the maturity in critical
thinking skills to sign a contract to
vote or even get a tattoo how can they
possibly be mature enough to understand
and consent to the life-changing
implications of these drastic procedures
they cannot
and that's why the adults in their lives
must protect them
but parents are being emotionally
manipulated into believing that unless
they let their child pursue hormones in
surgery that suicide is on the table
parents are sidelined and excluded from
the conversation as so-called experts
dictate what they think is best for the
child
why would anyone coax a child down a
path of permanent sterility well let's
follow the money
the gender business is booming
hospitals advertise Top surgery for
girls as young as 15 years old as a
doctor at Vanderbilt said it's a huge
money maker
some Market analysts predict that the
gender affirming care will reach 5
billion dollars in the United States
Alone by the end of this decade
knows boys cannot be girls and girls
cannot be boys
foreign
on every cell of our body and no amount
of medical interventions will change
that
our children are being sold a lie so
let's give kids real help not by
permanently altering their bodies that
by treating their psychological and
mental health needs Let's help children
love and recognize their bodies and
teach them the true human flourishing
starts with living at peace with your
body
the vast majority of children who are
distressed with their biological sex and
allowed to progress through their
natural puberty come to live at peace
with their bodies don't turn them into a
permanent medical patient
so to parents give your children the
freedom to be who they are give them
compassionate support and help them
learn to embrace their bodies
[Music]
[Applause]
to doctors and medical professionals
remember your oath to do no harm
[Applause]
history will not look kindly on those
who hurt the most vulnerable Among Us
and to the lawmakers of Tennessee and
Beyond shut it down
our laws and policies must promote human
flourishing not stifle it we must pass
Common Sense laws that protect minors
from predatory
life-altering and irreversible
experimentation let's keep kids first
thank you and next please welcome
filmmaker political activist writer and
Tennessee and Robbie Starbuck
[Applause]
hello Tennessee
[Music]
you know what before we begin
um I have a challenge for y'all if you
if you're gonna vote Republican in
November I want you to call me a fascist
and chant throughout my entire speech
okay
the whole thing you got to call me a
fascist but only if you're going to vote
Republican in November and you're going
to get a Republican president in 2024.
[Applause]
so I want to ask you a question why are
we here today
you
your only part right if you're saying to
end this mutilation of children to stop
these irreversible hormones and sex
changes on children who cannot consent
the truth is we're here because of you
we're here because you cared enough to
stand up to make noise to let your
lawmakers know that you demanded that
they took action Tennessee is able
Tennessee is able to stand up and to
show the nation how you get this done to
ban these irreversible harmful surgeries
on children and I have news for the
people in the middle we will ban these
surgeries
[Applause]
you know it's interesting to hear them
call this fascism when you stand up for
children the same people who want to
force your kids in school to have
pornography in their school libraries
and in in the libraries themselves for
kids to check out they're the same
people who throw their political
opposition in prison who stifle your
free speech online who censor every
thought that they don't agree with and
then have the nerve to show up and call
us fascists
[Applause]
I have news for them this doesn't stop
here this is step one this is step one
your entire far left communist agenda
and yes I use the word communist because
that is what you are
my family came from Cuba where they
survived communism once and we do not
fear you the people of Tennessee do not
fear you we look you in the eye and we
tell you your day has come your time is
over we will stand up we will stop you
we will face you down anytime anywhere
and we will beat you on the issues at
The Ballot Box and you will not take an
inch in this state from here on out
so get the moving trucks ready because
this isn't the state for you
[Applause]
you know you guys you're the coach
you're the coach of this team and we see
it Tennessee Vols who's who's evolves
fan here
we can see there what happens when you
get a good coach that recruits the right
players and has a great game plan so
make sure you treat Politics the same
way you recruit the right people support
the people who are going to stand up who
are going to fight and make sure the
lawmakers know you've got their back if
they take these fights on because
[Music]
you are that coach and you're what we
need in Tennessee not just to show up
today but to show up every day to not
relent to stand up on a whole host of
issues to make sure that this is a state
where our children are free from the
clutches of these communist tyrants who
want to control every part of their
lives free from their discrimination
against the unvaccinated free from their
discrimination against those who want to
save children from these surgeries and
free from their censorship this is not a
state for their ideology it's a state
where children will be safe
thank you guys
[Applause]
and you know what before I go I have a
question for you because we have a lot
of lawmakers here okay we know they know
we want this band and it is going to be
banned in Tennessee but I want to take a
show of hands
how many of you would also like to ban
drag shows for children let the
lawmakers know
and how many of you want to ban
pornography in libraries and at schools
how many of you want to ban medical
establishments like Vanderbilt from
discriminating against six-month-old
child which they did earlier this year
and wouldn't let him get a heart
transplant over vaccination status
so lawmakers you're all here behind me
you saw the people you know what they
want now let's get it done and protect
the children of Tennessee
[Applause]
next up
we've got evolutionary biologist
journalist and defender of free speech
within the sex and gender debate please
welcome Dr Colin Wright
hello
thank you all for being here
my name is Colin Wright I'm an
evolutionary biologist perhaps best
known for arguing the now controversial
position the biological sex is real
there's only two sexes
the differences between males and
females matter and that women are adult
human females
you might be wondering why this is
relevant here at a rally about ending
child mutilation
but it's actually extremely relevant
because the justifications given for
performing these horrific surgeries on
children are rooted in absurd reality
denying pseudoscience about basic
biology
it's a pseudoscience that denies the
existence of males and females
it's a pseudoscience that says that
biological sex is just an arbitrary
social construct
it's a pseudoscience that says that a
person's identity determines their
biology and it's a pseudoscience that
says that you can be born in the wrong
body which is demonstrated by having
preferences in behaviors that are
typically associated with the opposite
sex
most people don't realize how much our
major scientific and medical
institutions have been captured by this
pseudoscience literally claiming that
girls who are tomboys and boys who are
effeminate are literally transgender
but the American Psychological
Association the endocrine Society the
American Psychiatric association and
even the CDC to name only a few
literally Define someone being
transgender as a person whose expression
or behavior does not conform to that
which is typically associated with their
sex
that's their definition go look it up if
you don't believe me
it doesn't get much clearer than that
if you have a daughter who is not an
effeminate girl
she's actually a boy
if you have a son who is not a masculine
boy according to them he's actually a
girl
or even something else entirely
different altogether
[Music]
this is absurd in the extreme
[Applause]
we know that if left alone many of these
non-conforming children will grow up to
be normal healthy gay adults
but now because of gender ideology these
children are being told that they have a
mismatch between their gender identity
and their biological sex and that this
mismatch can be fixed with puberty
blockers cross-sex hormones and
experimental surgeries
in addition to these beliefs defying all
we know to be scientifically true about
basic biology
they are also grotesque and Evil
what is occurring at Vanderbilt health
and Hospitals and Clinics all over the
country and the name of this gender
pseudoscience is a medical Scandal of
horrifying proportions and it has to end
right now
thank you
[Music]
all right guys have you had a I know
you've had some fun here in the middle
but I have a question for y'all if you
really care about children the people
who are coming up here were children
when they were lied to by this system
that you defend
so if you have any respect for them
you'll listen You'll stop this obscene
ridiculous childish behavior but even
with that said I just want to let you
know
that God Made You Beautiful whether you
are male or female
that we love you that God loves you
and that we're so sorry that you've been
lied to exploited and now you're in
trauma mode where you can't even
entertain any other thought because
you're so scared and upset
it's so sad
we hope that one day you'll join us and
you'll have compassion for the
vulnerable compassion for the children
who have been maimed and abused and with
that said I want to invite two Heroes
our first hero coming up
is the founder of Trey voices and he was
also one of the heroes of Matt's film
what is a woman
he knows that firsthand the
life-threatening dangers and
complications of so-called gender
affirming care
please welcome Scott Nugent
[Music]
my name's Scott Newton
you may have seen me in a little
documentary I made a while back called
what is a woman
during that interview I had no clue who
Matt Walsh was I just thought wow this
dude has a really really great beard
I was the trans man who was called the
hero and matched groundbreaking
documentary The Hero that's pushing it
all I did was tell the truth and the
truth is is that I'm a woman and I will
never be a man
no one could change their sex medical
transition is experimental cosmetic and
it only creates an illusion of the
opposite sex for Comfort but medical
transition doesn't cure anything as
Society is being led to believe
but who I am my most important role is
that of a parent to three incredible
children
[Applause]
I'm a mother
and as a woman who has given birth
carried life
as someone who fell for the Relentless
onslaught of glitter bombs and unicorn
farts
I'm here today to put an end to the idea
of the medical transitioning children is
about human rights
it is not it's about money
[Applause]
we need to stop pushing puberty blockers
hormones and surgeries on Children and
Youth
stop telling kids they were born in the
wrong body
they are just different
and different is okay
in fact different
it's a superpower
you see the truth is that awkward
children the gifted the mentally ill the
autistic the abused the same sex
attracted are being targeted as a new
cash cow called transgender health
the series of dangerous experimental
procedures
that has no long-term study that says
it's safe or beneficial
[Music]
[Applause]
how are we butchering an entire
generation of Youth in the name of
Tolerance and acceptance
this is hypocritical
these kids not accepting their bodies
I can keep going louder if you want me
to
[Applause]
[Music]
kids that are drastically changing their
physical appearance through puberty
blockers hormones and surgeries is in
itself the act of intolerance
[Applause]
market research predicts that gender
affirming care will generate more than 5
billion dollars by the end of the decade
if the current rate of kids that are
being transitioned continues we're going
to have a whole generation of children
lifelong patients without having one
single disease
[Music]
if I as an adult couldn't resist the
temptation of a quick fix Elixir do you
really think someone with an immature
frontal lobe can
these children need people in their
lives to help them Embrace accept and
love themselves for who they are
not a delusion of something they will
never become
there are many reasons a child or
teenager might think that they're
transgender the transgender is not a
condition it's a verb it's something you
do through a choice you make no one is
born in the wrong body that's hogwash
there are major mental medical
organizations calling on big Tech and
the Department of Justice to investigate
prosecute and silence us but the truth
is on our side
a lot is happening exciting progress
being made all around the nation with
Robin lundstrom in Arkansas to lawmakers
here in Tennessee and many states
working on legislation
Vanderbilt Hospital
I can go louder
Vanderbilt Hospital temporary halted
performing gender affirming surgeries on
minors thanks to the pressure of the
People Like Us
[Applause]
you may not know that I've been in this
fight for three and a half years I found
in an organization and I need your help
it's called tray voices its mission is
to scream louder
that medical transition is no place for
a child
it's about the oldest breed since the
beginning of time money
if everyone knew the facts then we would
be calling it what it is child abuse
my only objective with Trey voices is to
transfer my passion and experience as a
trans man as a lesbian double quoted on
the rainbow
encourage everyone to talk to your
children
your parents your sisters your brothers
your cousins your neighbors your
co-workers I want to inspire people to
have those difficult conversations with
people who might not agree with them
I want you to do your work get outside
the Twitter Echo chamber
this debate is not political not about
human rights and we need everyone in
Tennessee and abroad to be brave enough
to release their own screams and join
together with millions in unison for
something we all are together human
beings
[Applause]
one colossal Scream the medical
transition is not for a child because
within this debate
a bigot today is a hero tomorrow
my question is
are you willing to take the heat today
to be a hero tomorrow to save a
generation of children
because our children deserve us to adult
better
[Applause]
our next speaker was a young teenager
when she saw professional help but
instead fast-tracked into a medical
gender transition as so many have
she knows now fights for the rights of
Children and Families Across the Nation
and before I welcome this incredible
young woman I want to ask the crowd to
listen because we care about the D
transitioners that have been left behind
we care about their voices social media
wants to censor their voices and their
voices are so important
because there's only one group of people
embracing them after they've been spit
out and exploited by this system and it
is not the people screaming in their
faces so please give a very big welcome
for Chloe Cole
[Applause]
thank you
hi there everybody my name is Chloe Koh
and
I flew out here all the way from
California
so
for those of you who don't know me
I am a former transgender kid
I'm biologically female but throughout a
good portion of my adolescence I
identified as male
I started by socially transitioning at
12 meaning I cut my hair shorter started
buying clothes boys clothing and asked
my family to refer to me by a new name
that I chose
from the looks of it you could probably
tell that it didn't work out
no
thank you
[Applause]
a lot of You Must Be Wondering
how does this happen
what led up to this
well there's several factors that make
our youth quite vulnerable
I actually had a relatively normal early
childhood
I had interest that were typical of a
girl my age I loved pink purple and blue
skirts dresses necklaces dolls and I
also like drawings video games I'm
playing in the dirt or with my older
brother's Legos or Nerf guns or toy
trucks
as I got older I started to associate
with and relate more to boys and I found
it more and more difficult to connect
with or even understand other girls my
age
I started puberty at roughly nine years
old so from a very young age I dealt
with both my peers and adults making
uncomfortable or even hurtful comments
on my developing body
I moved neighborhoods before entering
middle school and I turned to the
internet because I had so few friends in
person
little did I know that as soon as I made
my first Instagram account at 11 I would
immediately be recommended no bombarded
with trans identifying kids unachievable
body standards and even softcore porn
I never stood a chance because that was
just the beginning
postmodern feminism taught me that
throughout all of human history women
have been suppressed and oppressed and
still are to this day today's
intersectional feminism has very little
to do with women's rights it has
devolved into infringing upon the rights
of others
while reducing women to sex objects in a
costume that men can wear when they want
to taste the rainbow
it is clear why I despise the idea of
growing from a girl into a woman
but as a kid I couldn't reason properly
or introspect well enough to understand
why I felt this way
I fell victim to the idea that I was
actually a boy trapped within a girl's
body and I began to resent myself in a
way that felt more consistent with my
so-called gender identity
I came out to my parents with a letter
that I left on the table
asking them to refer to me by the name
Leo and call me their son
they wanted to support me but they were
at a loss of what to do for me and so
they turned to the help of healthcare
professionals who went on to conference
them into giving up their role as
parents and letting me do as I please
we had no idea these so-called doctors
and therapists were just butchers and
Liars
[Applause]
they told my parents that it was a life
or death choice and if they chose not to
accept me as their son they would
certainly end up with a dead daughter
I thought that by starting cross-sex
hormones my body would become more
consistent with my real gender identity
the only person to question this other
than my initially reluctant parents was
an endocrinologist who refused to
medicalize me because he was wary of how
it could affect my brain development
he was the only doctor I saw who didn't
immediately affirm my identity and
choices and I wouldn't be your surprise
if he eventually resigned or was fired
for safeguarding younger patients
my gender specialist expressed
frustration and immediately referred me
to another endocrinologist who was quick
to give me consent forms for puberty
blocking medication and injectable
testosterone
I remember her asking my 13 year old
self
are you aware you may experience atrophy
as some reproductive organs are you
aware that this may affect your ability
to have children in the future
it didn't matter what she told me I did
not have the mental faculties at 13
years old to be able to make an informed
decision that would permanently impact
My overall health and stun my
development
[Applause]
neither did I at 15 when I sought to
remove my breasts after two
uncomfortable years of binding my
breasts in the world with a compression
device called a breast binder
I wanted a way out I wanted to stop
wearing this binder or going on runs
swimming or walking home from school in
a hundred degree weather
I want it to look more like boys my age
and most importantly I wanted to avoid
the sexual attention that came with
having a visibly feminine chest
I was groped at school in a classroom a
place where I thought I would be safe
that was the final straw
I was afraid of being sexually assaulted
again I wanted this part of my body gone
and now it is and it will be that way
for the rest of my life because I was
allowed to make an adult decision as a
traumatized 15 year old
the next question is
just how often does this happen
conservatives in the past have written
the trans moving off as a circus act
that is not warrant meaningful political
discussion many on the right have been
made aware of the trans kids epidemic an
indoctrination in our schools only as of
this year
trans rights activists often outright
deny that children diagnosed with gender
dysphoria are ever medicalized but when
they're presented with evidence that it
does in fact happen they attempt to
justify it they'll go back on their
statements and then say that it's
actually a good thing
and to deny children of these barbaric
treatments is to deny them of
life-saving Health Care
[Applause]
these euphemisms are common and they
downplay the reality of medical
transition
some say that transition regret is
incredibly rare and that the reason that
transgender individuals you transition
is almost always due to external factors
such as social pressures or low income
this could not be any more false
a new day transitioner
often a minor reaches out to me on
nearly a daily basis
this is an epidemic
I see the transitioners expressed a
regret online and get bombed with hatred
by trans activists who have millions of
followers
they need to silence any dissent in
order to maintain the carefully
constructed narrative
as soon as I even expressed regret
I was met with hatred by the same people
who encouraged and celebrated every
milestone in my transition
I was told that I was a nuisance at best
and a harmful Force to other real
transgender people at worst just for
admitting my mistake
they said to me that I was only a
spoiled brat who manipulated and hurt my
parents and family
they said that I didn't deserve to go on
testosterone or undergo mastectomy
now
that part is true because I deserved so
much better
[Music]
[Applause]
children with gender dysphoria deserve
so much better
[Applause]
they deserve adults who love and care
for them when the world is preying on
them they deserve to just be kids as
somebody who knows this process well I
feel called to educate parents on the
harms that are being cast on their
children
harms that ultimately led to the
mutilation of my own body if I can reach
even one child with my story and change
the trajectory of their life I would
consider my mission successful
[Applause]
in closing we must run not walk to the
places and people that need to hear this
cry in the most vulnerable end child
mutilation
thank you thank you so much
come on
one more big round of applause for Scott
and Chloe
[Applause]
this is uh where I'm gonna sign off guys
and we're gonna have our next speakers
this is where the rubber meets the road
our legislatures okay the people who
have the power to change this in our
state I want you guys to get loud
because they need to hear us they need
to hear our voice we're not going to be
quiet anymore we are going to ban child
mutilation in the state of Tennessee
[Music]
we're gonna protect children and we're
going to get louder because the voices
of those Heroes need to be heard they
deserve to be heard and we are going to
protect children from One More Story
like that from happening
[Applause]
please welcome former prosecutor and the
House of Representatives majority leader
for the great state of Tennessee
representative William Lamberth
[Applause]
Arizona
thank y'all for being here today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
before I begin my prepared remarks I
want to say this
for those of you that came out today to
support kids like Chloe I commend you
but for those of you that while that
young lady was pouring out her heart to
you
that shouted at her and cursed at her
and derided every word she was saying
shame on you because you're not here for
kids
[Applause]
I want to thank the daily wire and
especially Matt Walsh for their work on
the critically important issues of
bringing us here together today
[Applause]
if not from Matt and his team a certain
University Medical Center just down the
road would still be performing child
mutilation surgeries like what happened
to Chloe
this madness is not unique to Nashville
we need to make this horrific practice
illegal in Tennessee
my colleagues at stand with me today
agree and I think we're going to be able
to protect children with your help we
need to make surgical mutilation for the
purpose of altering the appearance of a
child illegal
amen
but we can't do it alone
we need everyone standing here with us
today to support a legislative solution
and make it illegal once and for all
[Music]
now some of these doctors may actually
think they're helping these children but
they aren't some of them set out right
that they perform these surgeries
because it's profitable that child then
becomes a patient for life I'm a dad
myself and I'll tell you what that makes
me angry no child should ever have a
surgery no parent should ever consent to
a surgery until they know the full risk
that are associated with that surgery
I've spoken to multiple pediatricians
right here in the state of Tennessee who
are deeply concerned about what's
becoming wildly
perceived as normal in their field the
immediate American Academy of pediatric
discourages medical professioners from
questioning a minor self-reported gender
identity that's wrong part of this
process is to question it part of any
honest process is to question it the
only way you get to an answer is to
question it first
[Applause]
[Music]
almost overnight an entire woke medical
industry has emerged advocating to allow
children to Define their own disorder
and prescribe the remedy children are
receiving experimental treatments that
are harmful and irreversible
no child should ever be put in the
position to make it a permanent
life-altering decision to harm and
dispigure their body in this way
they can't possibly understand the
future ramifications of that least of
all a child under distress because they
are experiencing gender confusion take
our time make sure that child receives
the love that Chloe talked about just a
moment ago the support the guidance so
that they can make that decision as an
adult if they want to with their eyes
wide open to what the risks truly are
if you're concerned about this as I am
I'm asking you not to stand in the
shadows do what you're doing today join
us in supporting this legislation that
will be filed soon call your state
representatives call your state senators
and tell them how important this is to
you
let your voice be heard together I
guarantee you we can help protect our
children
[Music]
thank you very much for coming out here
today all of you this is what America is
all about and right now I'd like to
invite to the stage for some words
Senator Jack Johnson the majority leader
of the state senate and his colleagues
thank you all very much
[Applause]
thank you leader lambreth good afternoon
everyone isn't it great to be a
Tennessean today
[Applause]
I want to introduce some of my
colleagues from the Tennessee State
Senate we're going to get something done
about this this year I'm
I'm very pleased to be joined by Senator
Ed Jackson Senator Don White Senator
Janice bowling we're here representing
the Tennessee State Senate
[Applause]
I want to thank Matt Walsh and the team
at Daily wire for the work they've done
on this important issue and for bringing
us here today
I got a question for you isn't it great
that Matt Walsh is now Tennessean
[Applause]
isn't it great that Matt Walsh won't
back down to the woke left
I'm here to tell you today we won't
either
well I'm thinking people let me thank
you for joining us here today to stand
up for the children of Tennessee leader
Lambeth and I have been working on
legislation along with others and that
legislation will be filed early next
month one of the very first bills that's
going to be filed for the upcoming
general assembly is a bill to end the
practice of irreversible body alter
altering surgeries on minor children
here in the state of Tennessee
[Applause]
this is a this is a priority for many of
our colleagues in the general assembly
and I'm confident that with your help we
will pass this legislation
overwhelmingly the time it to act is now
we must protect our children here in
Tennessee
[Applause]
and I want you to feel good about the
fact that we can do it we've proven that
Tennessee is a conservative leader in
many many areas we're the least indebted
state in the nation we're the lowest tax
state in the nation we have the fastest
growing economy in the nation we stood
up to Joe Biden's unconstitutional
vaccine mandates
and by the way
I don't care what the liberal
bureaucrats and the CDC say in Tennessee
your children will never be forced to
get the coven shot
I want Tennessee to be a leader on this
issue as well we all do
we're going to ban permanent
life-altering medical procedures we will
get it done you have our word
[Applause]
now I have the honor of introducing
someone who really needs no introduction
certainly not here in Tennessee
listen she's not a biologist but unlike
Justice katanji Brown Jackson I'm pretty
sure she can tell you who a woman is
ladies and gentlemen the senator from
the great state of Tennessee Marcia
Blackburn
[Applause]
thank you all
let me tell you the great work that
William and Jack are doing to lead the
Tennessee General Assembly we are so
fortunate to be here in Tennessee
they are doing a great job making
certain that they're protecting
Tennessee families and I know that they
are going to do a great job in this
coming General Assembly they've told you
it is children's first Children First
and Families First for them in Tennessee
foreign
daily wire what an amazing job and we
[Music]
we are all here today because of this
information that Matt brought forward
and showed what was taking place just
down the street right here in Nashville
and showing how the radical left is
trying to put their woke agenda
on every single family in this state and
in this country and since the pandemic
began
the left has been trying to tell you how
to take care of your children they've
been trying to take the the health care
decisions away from parents and to let
the government make those decisions but
we will not let them do that here in
Tennessee
[Applause]
[Music]
you know it was appalling and shocking
to hear a medical professional say
that they were going to put profits in
front of children and in front of
children's hat health and I am so
grateful that every one of you are here
today to make your voice heard on this
issue so thank you for doing that
[Applause]
and I want you to know I will do
everything that I can do at the federal
level to make certain that we protect
our children and that we make certain
that families and parents are making
decisions for their children
we have to make certain that we in these
practices and make certain that we
protect the next generation of American
citizens and keep them from being the
target of the liberal left they cannot
use our children for profit and for
political gain we in Tennessee will not
stand for that
last month I sent a letter over to the
FDA and the CDC and calling for an
investigation of these puberty blockers
and to see what is happening with using
these off-labeled drugs
on children and we know from the experts
that there have not been the clinical
trials to look at the long-term effects
for this and as you would expect I am
yet to get an answer
from the Biden Administration on this
issue
but we're going to keep working and
we're going to start here in Tennessee
we are going to carry this movement to
take care of our children to end this
child mutilation we're going to take it
to every state in the country
[Applause]
look you all are happy warrior Freedom
Fighters and you are not going to let
the left get their way with our children
so
I want you to get busy today
and let's make certain that we get out
and that we voted on November 8th we
fire Nancy Pelosi and Chuck Schumer
[Applause]
let's make certain that here in
Tennessee we re-elect Jack and William
and the other state reps and state
senators who are standing here with you
making certain that we are going to take
action here in Tennessee
so stand with me let's keep fighting
let's make certain that we protect these
children let's make certain that on
November 8th everybody
is out to vote let's take this as our
goal we win in Tennessee and we take our
movement to other states thank you all
all right
now
I was uh I was only supposed to speak
once today but the trolls in the
audience gave me such a warm reception I
thought I'd come out again
now
because you see that's the way it works
if you try to uh shut me up or drown me
out I just keep talking that's the way
this goes
and that's that's true of everybody here
right the more they try to drown us out
the louder we're going to be
I want to just make as we wrap things I
just want to make one point
I'm actually very glad that these people
have decided to come and be a part of
this event because for one thing maybe
they've been exposed to a little bit of
Truth they don't get a lot of that so
maybe if you've heard some truth tonight
but also we see the contrast we see the
contrast between people who care about
children who care about families and
those who just try to drown us out
and and who cannot engage in the
conversation we see the contrast there
which is very important but here's the
other thing
the reason they're acting this way is
because they are losing and they know it
they're losing
you guys are losing
because we're going to pass this bill
and it's going to be illegal in this
state that's going to happen no matter
what they say
and they will continue to lose as long
as we continue to fight all across the
country so when you go home I want you
to call your Congressional
Representatives I want you to go online
I want you to speak to everybody you
know walk in the truth speak the truth
to everyone
as long as we do that then we win
remember
the thing to bring home is that this is
as I said to start this is really and
truly a battle of good versus evil this
is black and white it is very clear who
stands on the side of Truth and that is
us
so let's keep the fight up everybody
thank you everyone for being here
thank you
thank you
thank you
[Applause]